okay so we're on uh rumble okay and it's  insane rumble's this right-wing platform  it's a free speech platform and all of  this stuff the comments are wild check  out a couple of these boss 666 said  again you youtube vaccine propagandist  now if you accept the science and  understand the science you're a  propagandist  ramsey says alex jones could eat pacman  for breakfast  you know i think that that actually that  actually might be true if you look a  picture at a picture of me next to alex  jones i it's certainly not me who would  eat him i think that that actually is uh  is is true and lastly pacman is a [ __ ]  he's the type of fool that will tell you  everything is fine on the left  as their house is burning down around  them that one's so dumb i won't even  respond